hello everyone and welcome back into
week four um so for week four uh
it's gonna come in two halves so today
i'm going to talk about machine
translation related topics and then in
the second half of the week we take a
little bit of a break from learning more
and more neural networks topics and talk
about
final projects but also some practical
tips for
building your network systems
so for today's lecture
this is an important content for lecture
so first of all i'm going to introduce a
new task
machine translation
and it turns out that
task is a major use case of a new
architectural technique to teach you
about deep learning which is sequence to
sequence models and so we'll spend a lot
of time on those and then
there's a crucial way that's been
developed to improve sequence to
sequence models which is the idea of
attention and so that's what i'll talk
about in the final part of the class
um just checking everyone's keeping up
with what's happening so first of all
um assignment
three is due today so hopefully you've
all gotten your new dependency passes
parsing text well
um at the same time assignment 4 is out
today and really today's lecture is the
primary content for what you'll be using
for building your assignment four
systems
switching it up for a little
for assignment four we give you a mighty
two extra days um so you get nine days
for it and it's due on thursday
on the other hand do please be aware
that assignment 4 is bigger and harder
than the previous assignments so do make
sure you get started on it early
and then as i mentioned thursday i'll
turn to final projects
okay so let's get straight into this um
with
machine translation so very quickly i
wanted to tell you a little bit about
you know
where we were and what we did
before we get to neural machine
translation and so let's do the
pre-history of machine translation so
machine translation is the task of
translating a sentence x from one
language which is called the source
language to another language the target
language forming a sentence y
so we start off with a source language
sentence x
lo mein
um and then we translate it and we get
out the translation man is born free but
everywhere he is in chains
okay so there's our machine translation
okay so in the early 1950s they started
to be work on machine translation um and
so it's actually thing about computer
science if you find things um that have
machine in the name most of them are old
things um
so um and this really kind of came about
in the u.s context in the context of the
cold war um so there was this desire to
keep tabs on what the russians were
doing and people had the idea that
because some of the earliest computers
had been so successful at um doing code
breaking during the second world war
then maybe we could set um early
computers to work
during the cold war to do translation um
and hopefully this will play and you'll
be able to hear it here's a little video
clip um showing some of the earliest
work um in machine translation
from 1954.
[Music]
they hadn't reckoned with ambiguity when
they set out to use computers to
translate languages
a 500 000 super calculator most
versatile electronic brain known
translates russian into english instead
of mathematical wizardry a sentence in
russian
one of the first non-numerical
applications of computers it was hyped
as the solution to the cold war
obsession of keeping tabs on what the
russians were doing claims were made
that the computer would replace most
human translators
of course you're just in the
experimental stage when you go in for
full scale production what will the
capacity be we should be able to do
about with a modern commercial computer
uh about one to two million worth an
hour and this will be quite an adequate
speed to cope with the whole output of
the soviet union in just a few hours
computer time a week when do you have to
be able to achieve the speed if our
experiments go well then perhaps within
uh five years or so and finally mr
mcdaniel does this mean the end of human
translators it's a yes for uh
translators of scientific and technical
material but as regards poetry and
novels no i don't think we'll ever
replace the translators of that type of
material mr mcdaniel thank you very much
but despite the hype it ran into deep
trouble
um yeah so
the experiments did not go well
um
and so you know in retrospect it's not
very surprising that the early work did
not um
work out very well i mean this was in
the sort of really beginning of the
computer age in the 1950s but it was
also the beginning of you know people
starting to understand the science of
human languages the field of linguistics
so really people had not much
understanding of either side of what was
happening um so what you had was people
are trying to write systems on really
incredibly primitive computers right you
know it's probably the case that now if
you if you have a usbc power brick that
it has more computational capacity
inside it than the computers that they
were using to translate um and so
effectively what you were getting were
very simple rule-based systems and word
lookup so there was so like dictionary
look up a word and get its translation
but that just didn't work well because
human languages are much more complex
than that often words have many meanings
and different senses as we've sort of
discussed about a bit
often there are idioms you need to
understand the grammar to rewrite the
sentences so for all sorts of reasons it
didn't work well and this idea was
largely canned in particular there was a
famous us government report in the mid
1960s the alpaca report which basically
concluded this wasn't working
oops
okay
work then did revive in ai at doing
rule-based methods of machine
translation in the um 90s
but when things really became alive um
was once you got into the mid
90s and when they were in the period of
statistical nlp that we've seen in other
places in the course
and then the idea began can we start
with just data about translation
ie sentences and their translations and
learn a probabilistic model that can
predict the translations of fresh
sentences so suppose we're translating
french into english so what we want to
do is build a probabilistic model that
given a french sentence we can say
what's the probability of different
english translations and then we'll
choose the most likely
translation um we can then
found it was found to
felicitus to break this down into two
components by just reversing this with
bayes rule so if instead we had a
probability
over
english sentences p of y
um and then a probability of a french
sentence given an english sentence that
people were able to make more progress
and it's not immediately obvious as to
why this should be because this is just
sort of a trivial rewrite with bayes
rule but it allowed the problem to be
separated into two parts which proved to
be more tractable so on the left hand
side you effectively had a translation
model where you could just give a
probability of words or phrases being
translated between the two languages
without having to bother about the
structural word order of the languages
and then on the right hand you saw
precisely what we spent a long time with
last week which is this is just a
probabilistic language model so if we
have a very good model of what good
fluent english sentences sound
like which we can build just from
monolingual data we can then get it to
make sure we're producing sentences that
sound good while the translation model
hopefully puts the right words into them
so how
do we learn the translation model since
we haven't covered that so the starting
point was to get a large amount of
parallel data which is human translated
sentences and this point is mandatory
that i show a particular a picture of
the rosetta stone which is the famous
original piece of parallel data that
allowed
the decoding of egyptian hieroglyphs
because it had the same piece of text in
different languages in the modern world
there are fortunately for people who
build natural language processing
systems quite a few places where
parallel data is produced in large
quantities so the european union
produces a huge amount of parallel text
across european languages
the french
sorry not the french the canadian
parliament conveniently produces
parallel text
between french and english and even
a limited amount in an institute
canadian
eskimo
and then the hong kong parliament
produces um english and chinese so
there's a fair availability from
different sources and we can use that to
build models
so how do we do it though all we have is
these sentences and it's not quite
obvious how to build a probabilistic
model out of those
well as before what we want to do is
break this problem down so in this case
what we're going to do is introduce an
extra variable which is an alignment
variable so a is the alignment variable
which is going to give a word level or
sometimes phrase level correspondence
between parts of the source sentence and
the target sentence
so this is an example of an alignment
and so if we could induce this alignment
between the two
sentences then we have can have
probabilities of pieces of how likely a
word or a short phrase is translated in
a particular way
and
in general you know alignment is working
out the correspondence between words
that is capturing
the grammatical differences
between languages so words will occur in
different orders in different languages
depending on whether it's a language
that puts on the subject before the verb
or the subject after the verb or the
verb before both the subject and the
object and
the alignments will also capture
something about differences about the
ways the word languages do things so
what we find is that we get every
possibility of how words can align
between languages so you can have words
that don't get translated at all in the
other language
so in french
you put a definite article the before
country names like japan so when that
gets translated to english you just get
japan so there's no translation of the
so it just goes away
um on the other hand you can get
many-to-one translations where one
french word
gets translated as several english words
so
for the last french word it's being
translated as aboriginal people as
multiple words
um you can get the reverse where you can
have several french words um that get
translated as one english word so nissan
application is getting translators
implemented
and you can get but even more
complicated um one so here we sort of
have
four english words being translated as
two french words but they don't really
break down and translate each other well
i mean these things don't only happen
across languages they also happen within
the language when you have different
ways of saying the same thing so another
way
you might have um expressed the poor
don't have any money is to say the poor
are moneyless and that's much more
similar um to how the french is being
rendered here and so even english to
english you have the same kind of
alignment problem
so in probabilistic or statistical
machine translation is more commonly
known
what we wanted to do is learn these
alignments
and there's a bunch of sources of
information you could use if you start
with parallel sentences
you can see how often words and phrases
co-occur in parallel sentences you can
look at their positions in the sentence
and
figure out what a good
alignments but alignments are a
categorical thing they're not
probabilistic and so they are latent
variables and so you need to use special
learning algorithms like the expectation
maximization algorithm for learning
about latent variables in the olden days
of cs224n before we started doing it all
with deep learning we spent tons of
cs224 in
dealing with latent variable algorithms
but these days we don't cover that at
all and you're going to have to go off
and see cs228 if you want to know more
about that and you know we're not really
expecting you to understand the details
here but i did then want to say a bit
more about how decoding was done um
in a statistical machine translation
system um so what we wanted to do is to
say we had a translation model and a
language model and we want to pick out
the most likely why there's the
translation of the sentence and
what kind of process could we use to do
that um well
you know the naive thing is to say well
let's just enumerate every possible y
and calculate its probability but we
can't possibly do that because there's a
number of
translation sentences in the target
language that's exponential on the
length of the sentence so that's way too
expensive so we need to have some way to
break it down more and well we had a
simple way um for language models we
just generated words one at a time and
laid out the sentence and so that seems
a reasonable thing to do but here we
need to deal with the fact
that
things occur in different orders in
source languages and in translations
and so we do want to break it into
pieces with an independence assumption
like the language model but then we want
a way of breaking things apart and
exploring it in what's called a decoding
process
so this is the way it was done so we'd
start with a source sentence so this is
a german sentence
and as is um
standard
in german you're getting
this second position verb
so that's probably not in the right
position for where the english
translation is going to be so we might
need to rearrange the words so what we
have is based on the translation model
we have
words or phrases that are reasonably
likely um translations of each german
word or sometimes a german phrase so
these are effectively the lego pieces
out of which we're going to
want to create the translation
and so then inside that what we're going
making use of this data we're going to
generate the translation piece by piece
kind of like we did with our newer
language models so we're going to start
with an empty translation and then we're
going to say well we want to use one of
these lego pieces and so we could
explore different possible ones so
there's a search process but one of the
possible pieces is we could translate er
with he
or we could start the sentence
with r translating the second word so we
could explore
various likely possibilities and if
we're guided by our language model it's
probably much more likely to start the
sentence with he than it is to start the
sentence with r though r is not
impossible okay and then the other thing
we're doing with these little blotches
of black at the top we're sort of
recording which german words we've
translated and so we explore forward in
a
translation process
and we could decide that we could
translate next the second word goes
or we could translate the negation here
and translate that as does not
when we explore various continuations
and in the process i'll go through in
more detail later when we do the neural
equivalent we sort of do this search
where we explore likely translations and
prune and eventually we've translated
the whole of the input sentence and
worked out a fairly likely translation
he does not go home and that's what
we'll use as the translation
okay
so in the period from about
1997 to around um 2013
um statistical machine translation was a
huge research field
the best systems were extremely complex
and they had hundreds of details that i
certainly haven't mentioned here the
systems had lots of separately designed
and built components so i mentioned a
language model and a translation model
but they had lots of other components
for reordering models and inflection
models and other things there was lots
of feature engineering
typically the models also made use of
lots of extra resources um and there
were lots of human effort to maintain um
but nevertheless they were already
fairly successful so um google translate
launched in the mid-2000s and people
thought wow this is amazing you could
start to get sort of semi-decent
automatic translations um
for different web pages
um but
that was chugging along well enough and
then we got to 2014
and really with enormous suddenness um
people then worked out ways of doing um
machine translation using a large neural
network and these large neural networks
proved to be just extremely successful
and largely blew away everything that
preceded it so for the next big part of
the lecture what i'd like to do
is tell you something about newer
machine translation
neural machine translation
well it means you're using a new network
to do machine translation but in
practice it's meant slightly more than
that it has meant that we're going to
build
one very large neural network which
completely does translation end to end
so we're going to have a large neural
network we're going to feed in the
source sentence into the input and
what's going to come out as the output
of the neural network
is the translation of the sentence we're
going to train that model end-to-end on
parallel sentences and it's the entire
system rather than being lots of
separate components as in an
old-fashioned machine translation system
and we'll see that in a bit um so these
neural network architectures are called
sequence to sequence models or commonly
abbreviated seek to seek um and
um
they involve
two neural networks here it says two
rnns the version i'm um presenting now
has two rnns but more generally they
involve two neural networks there's
one neural network that is going to
encode the source sentence so if we have
a source sentence here
we're going to encode that sentence and
well we know about a way that we can do
that
so using the kind of lstms that we saw
last class we can start at the beginning
and
go through a sentence and update the
hidden state each time and that will
give us a representation of the content
of the source sentence so
that's the first sequence model
um which encodes the source sentence and
we'll use the idea that the final hidden
state of the encoder
rnn is going to
in sense represent um the source
sentence and we're going to feed it
indirectly as the initial hidden state
for the decoder rnn so then on the other
side of the picture we have our decoder
rnn
and it's a language model that's going
to generate a target sentence
conditioned on
the
final hidden state of the encoder rnn so
we're going to start with the input of
start symbol we're going to feed in the
hidden state from the encoder rnn and
now this second green rnn
has completely separate parameters i
might just emphasize but we do the same
kind of lstm computations and generate a
first word of the sentence he
and so then doing lstm generation just
like last class we copy that down as the
next input
we run the next step of the lstm
generate another word hit copy it down
and chug along and
we've
translated the sentence right so this is
showing um the test time behavior um
when
we're generating the next sentence for
the training time behavior when we have
parallel sentences we're still using the
same kind of sequence to sequence model
but we're doing it with the decoder part
just like um training a language model
where we're wanting to do
teacher forcing and predict each word
that's actually found in the source
language sentence
um sequences sequence models have been
an incredibly
powerful
widely used workhorse in new neural
networks for nlp so although
you know historically
machine translation was the first big
use of them and is
sort of the canonical use they're used
everywhere else as well
so
you can do many other nlp tasks for them
so you can do summarization you can
think of text summarization as
translating a long text into a short
text
but you can use them for other things
that are in no way a translation
whatsoever so they're commonly used
for neural dialogue systems so the
encoder
will encode um the previous two
utterances say and then you will use the
decoder to generate a neck star trends
um
some other uses
are even freakier
but have proven to be quite successful
um
so
if you have any way of representing the
paths of a sentence as a string
and if you sort of think a little it's
fairly obvious how you can turn the
paths of a sentence into a string by
just making use of extra syntax like
parentheses or putting in explicit words
that are saying
left arc right arc um
shifts like the transition systems that
you used for assignment three well then
we could say
let's use the encoder
feed the input sentence to the encoder
and let it output the transition
sequence of our dependency parser and
somewhat surprisingly that actually
works well as another way to build
a dependency parser or other kinds of
parser
these models have also been applied not
just to natural languages but to other
kinds of languages
including music and also programming
language code so you can
train a seek to seek system where it
reads in
pseudocode in natural language and it
generates out python code and if you
have a good enough one it can do the
assignment for you
um
so the essential new idea here with our
sequence to sequence models is we have
an example of conditional language
models so
previously the main thing we were doing
was just so start at the beginning of
the sentence and
generate a sentence
based on nothing but here we have
something that is going to determine or
partially determined that is going to
condition what we should produce so we
have a source sentence and that's going
to strongly determine what is a good
translation
and so to achieve that
what we're going to do is have some way
of
transferring information about the
source sentence from the encoder to
trigger what the decoder should do
and the two standard ways of doing that
are you either feed in a hidden state as
the initial hidden state to the decoder
or sometimes you will feed something in
as the initial input to the decoder
and so the
in your mainstream translation our we're
directly calculating this conditional
model probability of target language
sentence given source language sentence
and so at each step as we break down the
word by word generation that we're
conditioning not only on previous words
of the target language but also each
time on our source language sentence x
because of this we actually know a ton
more about what our sentence that we
generate should be
so if you look at
the perplexities of these kind of
conditional language models you will
find and like the numbers i showed last
time they usually have almost frequently
low perplexities that you will have
models with perplexities that are
something like four or even less
sometimes you know 2.5 because you get a
lot of information about what words you
should be generating
okay
so then we have the same questions as we
had for language models in general how
to train a neural machine translation
system and then how to use it at runtime
so let's go through both of those in a
bit more detail
so the first step is we get a large
parallel corpus so we run off to the
european union
for example and we grab a lot of
parallel english french data from the
european parliament proceedings
so then once we have our parallel
sentences um what we're going to do is
take
um batches of source sentences and
target sentences
will encode the source sentence with our
encoder lstm
will
feed its final
hidden state into
a target
lstm and this one we are now then going
to train word by word by comparing what
it predicts is the most likely
word to be produced versus what the
actual first word and then the actual
second word is and to the extent that we
get it wrong
we're going to suffer some loss so this
is going to be the negative log
probability of
generating the correct next word he
and so on along the sentence and so in
the same way that we saw last time for
language models we can work out our
overall
loss for the sentence doing this teacher
forcing style generate one word at a
time calculate a loss relative to the
word that you should have produced
and so that loss then gives us
information that we can back propagate
through the entire network and the
crucial
thing about these sequence the sequence
models that has made them extremely
successful in practice is that the
entire thing is optimized as a single
system end to end so starting with our
final loss
we back propagate it right through the
system so we not only update all the
parameters of the decoder model but we
also update all of the
parameters of the encoder model which in
turn will influence what conditioning
gets passed over from the encoder to the
decoder
um
so this moment is a good moment for me
to return um to the three slides that i
um skipped i'm running out of time at
the end of last time which is to mention
multi-layer rnns um so the rnn's that
we've looked at so far uh already deep
on one dimension then unroll
horizontally over many time steps
but they've been shallow in that there's
just been a single layer of recurrent
structure above our sentences
we can also make them deepen the other
dimension by applying multiple rnn's on
top of each other and this gives us some
multi-layer rnn uh often also called a
stacked rnn
and having a
multi-layer rnn allows us the network to
compute more complex representations so
simply put
the lower rnns tend to compute lower
level features and the higher rnns
should compute higher level features
and just like in other neural networks
whether it's feed forward networks or
the kind of networks you see in vision
systems you get
much greater power and success by having
a stack of multi
multiple layers of recurrent neural
networks right that you might think that
all there are two things i could do i
could have a single lstm with a hidden
state of dimension 2000 or i could have
four layers of lstms with a hidden state
of
500 each and it shouldn't make any
difference because i've got the same
number of parameters roughly but that's
not true in practice it does make a big
difference and multi-layer or stacked
rnns are more powerful
so
uh could i ask you um
there's a good student question here
about what lower level versus higher
level features mean in this context sure
um yeah so i mean in some sense these
are kind of um somewhat flimsy ways
um
you know um
terms this meaning isn't precise um but
typically what that's meaning
is that lower level features and knowing
sort of more basic things about words
and
phrases so that commonly might be things
like what part of speech is this word or
are these words the name of a person or
the name of a company
whereas higher level features refer to
things that are at a higher semantic
level so knowing more about the overall
structure of a sentence knowing
something about what it means whether a
phrase has positive or negative
connotations um what its um
semantics are when you put together
several words into an idiomatic phrase
um roughly the higher level kinds of
things
okay
jump ahead
okay so
when we build
um
one of these end-to-end
neural machine translation systems if we
want them to work well
single layer lstm
encoder decode in your machine
translation systems just don't work well
but you can build something that is no
more complex than the model that i've
just explained now that does work pretty
well by making it a multi-layer
stacked lstm neural machine translation
system so therefore
the picture looks like this so we've got
this multi-layer lstm that's going
through the source sentence and so now
at each point in time we calculate a new
hidden representation that rather than
stopping there we sort of feed it as
into the input into another layer of
lstm
and we calculate in the standard way
it's new hidden representation and the
output of it we feed into a third layer
of lstm and so we run that right along
and so our
representation of the
source sentence from our encoder is then
this stack of three hidden layers
and then that we
use um
to then
feed in as the initial um as the initial
hidden layer into then sort of
generating
translations or
for training the model of comparing to
losses so this is kind of what the
picture of a
lstm encoder decoder your machine
translation system really looks like
so in particular um
you know to give you some idea of that
um so a 2017 paper um by denny brits and
others that what they found was that for
the encoder rnn
it worked best if it had two to four
layers and
four layers was best for the decoder rnn
and the details here like for a lot of
neural nets depends so much on what
you're doing and how much data you have
and things like that but you know as
rules of thumb to have in your head it's
almost invariably the case that having a
two layer
lstm works a lot better than having a
one layer lstm
after that things become much less clear
you know
it's not so infrequent that if you try
three layers it's a fraction better than
two but not really and if you try four
layers it's actually getting worse again
you know it depends on how much data etc
you have at any rate um it's normally
very hard with the kind of model
architecture that i just showed back
here to get better results with more
than four layers of lstm
normally to do
deeper
lstm models and get
even better results you have to be
adding extra skip connections of the
kind that i talked about at the very end
of
the last class
next week john is going to talk about
transformer-based networks
in contrast for fairly fundamental
reasons they're typically
much
deeper but we'll leave discussing them
until we
get on further
um
so that was how we trained the model um
so let's just go a bit more through what
the possibilities are for decoding and
explore a more complex form of decoding
than we've looked at the simplest way to
decode is the one that we've presented
so far so that we have our lstm we start
generate a hidden state
it has a probability distribution over
words and you choose the most probable
one the arg max and you say he and you
copy it down and you repeat over so
doing this is referred to as greedy
decoding taking the most probable word
on each step and it's sort of the
obvious thing to do
and doesn't seem like it could be a bad
thing to do
but
it turns out that it actually can be a
fairly problematic thing to do
and the idea of that is that you know
with greedy decoding you're sort of
taking locally what seems the best
choice and then you're stuck with it and
you have no way to undo decisions um
so
if um these examples have been using
this sentence about he hit me with a pie
going from translating from french to
english so you know if you start off and
you say okay ill the first word in the
translation should be he
um that looks good but then you um
and then you say well hit i'll generate
hit
then somehow the model thinks that the
most likely next word is hit after hit
is r and there are lots of reasons it
could think so um because after hit most
commonly there's a direct object now and
then you know he hit a car
he hit
a roadblock right so that's prett sounds
pretty likely but you know once you've
generated it there's no way to go
backwards and so you just have to keep
on going from there and you may not be
able to generate the translation you
want um
at best you can generate um he hit
a pie
oops um
something so we'd like to be able to
explore a bit more in generating our
translations
and well you know what could we do
well you know i sort of mentioned this
before looking at the statistical mt
models
overall what we'd like to do
is find
translations
that maximize
the probability of y given x and at
least if we know what the length of that
translation is
we can do that as a product of
generating a word at a time and so to
have a full model we also have to have a
probability distribution over how long
the translation length would be
so we could say this is the model and
let's you know
generate and score
all possible sequences y
using this model and that's where that
then requires generating an exponential
number of translations and is far far
too expensive
so beyond greedy decoding the
the most important method that is used
and you'll see lots of places is
something called beam search decoding
and so this isn't what
neural well any kind of machine
translation is one place where it's
commonly used but this isn't a method
that's specific to me machine
translation you find lots of other
places including all other kinds of
sequences sequence models it's not the
only other decoding method once when we
got on to the
language generation class we'll see a
couple more but this is sort of the next
one that you should know about
so beam searches idea is that you're
going to
keep
some hypotheses to make it more likely
that you'll find a good generation while
keeping the search tractable
so what we do is ch choose a beam size
and for neural mt the beam size is
normally fairly small something like
five to ten and at each step of the
decoder we're going to keep track of the
k most probable partial translations so
initial subsequences of what we're
generating which we call hypotheses
um so a hypothesis which is then sort of
the prefix of a translation has a score
which is this log probability up to
what's been generated so far so we can
generate that in the
typical way using our conditional
language model
so
as written all of the scores are
negative and so the least negative one i
the highest probability one is the best
one so what we want to do is search
for high probability hypotheses
so this is a heuristic method it's not
guaranteed to find the highest
probability decoding but at least it
gives you more of a shot than simply
doing
greedy decoding so let's go through an
example
to see how it works
so
in this case so i can fit it on a slide
the size of our beam is just two um
though normally um it would actually be
a bit bigger than that and the blue
numbers are the scores of the prefixes
so these are these log probabilities of
a prefix so we start off with our start
symbol and we're going to say okay
what are the two most likely words to
generate first according to our language
model and so maybe the first two most
likely words are he and i
and there are their log probabilities
then what we do next is for each
of these k hypotheses we find what are
likely words to follow them in
particular we find one of the k most
likely words to follow each of those so
we might generate he hit he struck i was
i got
okay so at this point it sort of looks
like we're heading down what will turn
into an exponential um true size tree
structure again but what we do now
is we work out the scores of each of
these partial hypotheses so we have
four partial hypotheses he hit he struck
i was i got and we can do that by taking
the previous score that we have the
partial hypothesis and adding on the log
probability of generating the next word
here here hit so this gives us scores
for each hypothesis and then we can say
which of those two partial hypotheses
because our beam size k equals two have
the highest score and so they are i was
and he hit so we keep those two
and ignore the rest
and so then for those two
we're going to generate um k hypotheses
for the most likely following word
he hit uh he hit me i was hit i was
struck um and again
now we want to find the k most likely
hypotheses
out of this full set and so that's going
to be he struck me and i was oh no
he struck me and he hit r
um so we keep just those ones
and then for each of those we generate
the k most likely next words
tart pie with on and then again we
filter back down to size k
by saying
okay the two most likely things here are
pie or width so we continue working on
those
generate things
find the two most likely
generate things find the two most likely
and at this point um we would generate
end of string and say okay we've got a
complete hypothesis he struck me with a
pie
um and we could then trace back um
through the tree um to obtain the full
hypothesis for this sentence
so that's most of the algorithm there's
one more detail
which is the stopping criterion so in
greedy decoding we usually
um decode until the model produces an n
token and when it produces the end token
we say we are done
in beam search decoding different
hypotheses may produce n tokens on
different time steps and so we don't
want to stop
as soon as one path through the search
tree has generated end because it could
turn out there's a different path
through the search tree which will still
prove to be better so what we do is sort
of put us put it aside as a complete
hypothesis
and continue exploring other hypotheses
via our beam search
and so usually we will then either stop
when we've
hit a cut-off length
or when we've completed
n
complete hypotheses
and then we'll look through
the hypotheses that we've completed and
say which is the best one of those and
that's the one we'll use
okay so at that point we have our list
of completed hypotheses
and we want to select the top one with
the highest score well that's exactly
what we've been computing each one has
a
probability
that we've worked out but it turns out
that we might not want to use that just
so naively because there turns out to be
a kind of a systematic problem which is
you know not as a theorem but in general
longer hypotheses have lower scores so
if you think about this as probabilities
of successively generating each word
that basically at each step you're
multiplying by another chance of
generating the next word probability and
commonly those might be you know 10 to
the minus three ten to the minus two so
just from the length of the sentence um
your probabilities are getting much
lower the longer that they go on in a
way that appears to be unfair since
although in some sense extremely long
sentences aren't as likely as short ones
they're not less likely by that much a
lot of the time we produce long
sentences so for example you know a
newspaper um
the
median length of sentences is over 20 so
you wouldn't want to be having a
decoding model when translating news
articles that sort of says oh just
generate two-word sentences they're just
way higher probability according to my
language model um so the commonest way
of dealing with that is that we
normalize by length um so if we're
working in log probabilities that means
taking dividing through by the length of
the sentence and then you have a per
word
log probability score
and you know
you can argue that this isn't quite
right
in some theoretical sense but in
practice it works pretty well and it's
very commonly used
um neural
translation
has proven to be
much much better i'll show you a couple
of statistics and about that in a moment
it has many advantages
um it gives better performance the
translations are better in particular
they're more fluent because newer
language models produce much more fluent
sentences
but also
they much better use context because
neural language models including
conditional neural language models give
us a very good way of conditioning on a
lot of context in particular we can just
run a long encoder and condition on the
previous sentence or we can translate
words well in context by making use of
neural context
neural models better understand
phrase similarities and phrases that
mean approximately the same thing um
and then
the
technique of optimizing all parameters
of the model end to end in a single
large neural network is just proved to
be a really powerful idea so
previously a lot of the time people were
building
separate components and tuning them
individually which just meant that they
weren't actually optimal when put into a
much bigger system
so really a
a hugely powerful guiding idea in neural
network land is if you can sort of build
one huge network and just optimize the
entire thing end to end that will give
you much better performance and
component-wise systems
we'll come back to the costs of that
later in the course
the the models are also actually great
in other ways they actually require much
less human effort to build
there's no feature engineering
there's
in general no language specific
components you're using the same method
for all language pairs
of course it's rare for things to be
perfect in every way
so neural machine translation systems
also have some disadvantages compared to
the older statistical machine
translation systems
they're less interpretable it's harder
to see why they're doing what they're
doing where you before you could
actually look at phrase tables and they
were useful
so they're hard to debug they also tend
to be sort of difficult to control
um so compared to anything like writing
rules um you can't really give much
specification as if you'd like to say oh
i'd like my translations to be more
casual or something like that
it's hard to know what they'll generate
so there are various safety concerns
um
i'll show a few examples of that
in just a minute but first before doing
that
quickly how do we
evaluate machine translation um the best
way to evaluate machine translation is
to show a human being who's fluent in
the source and target languages the
sentences and get them to give judgment
on how good a translation it is
but that's
expensive to do
and might not even be possible if you
don't have the right human beings around
so a lot of work was put into finding
automatic methods of scoring
translations that were good enough and
the most famous method of doing that is
what's called blue
and the way you do blue
is you have
a human translation or several human
translations of the source sentence and
you're comparing a machine-generated
translation to those pre-given human
written translations and you score them
for similarity
by calculating engram precisions i.e
words that overlap between
the computer and human written
translation diagrams trigrams and four
grams and then working
out a geometric average between overlaps
of n engrams plus there's a penalty for
two short system translations so blue
has proven to be a really useful
measure but it's an imperfect measure
that commonly there are many valid ways
to translate a sentence and so there's
some luck as to whether
the
human written translations you have
happen to correspond to which to what
might be a good translation from the
system
there's more to say about the details of
blue
and how it's implemented but you're
going to see all of that doing
assignment 4
because you will be
building your machine translation
systems and evaluating with them with
the
blue algorithm and their full details
about
blue in the assignment handout but at
the end of the day
blue gives the score between zero and a
hundred where
your score is a hundred if you're
exactly producing one of the human
written translations and zero if you
there's not even a single unigram that
overlaps between the two
with that rather brief intro i wanted to
show you sort of what happened in
machine translation
so machine translation
with statistical models phrase-based
statistical machine translation that i
showed at the beginning of the class had
been going on
since the mid 2000s decade and it had
produced sort of semi-good results of
the kind that are in google translate in
those days but by the time you'd entered
um the 2010s
basically progress and
statistical machine translation had
stalled
and you are getting barely any increase
over time and most of the increase in
time you were getting over time was
simply because you're training your
models on more data
um in those years
around the early 2010s
the big hope that most people had
someone asked what is the y-axis here
this y-axis is this blue score that i
told you about on the previous slide
in the early 2010s the big hope that
most people in the machine translation
field had was well if we built a more
complex kind of machine translation
model that knows about the syntactic
structure of languages that makes use of
tools like dependency parsers will be
able to build much better translations
and so those are the purple systems here
which i haven't described at all but
it's sort of as the years went by
it was pretty obvious
that that barely seemed to help
and so then
in the mid 2000 2010s
so in
2014 was the first modern attempt to
build a neural network for machine
translations and encoder decoder model
um and by the time it was sort of
evaluated in bake offs in 2015
it wasn't as good as what had been built
up over the preceding decade
but it's already getting pretty good but
what was found was that these newer
models just really opened up a whole new
pathway to start building much much
better machine translation systems and
since then
things have just sort of taken off and
year by year newer machine translation
systems are getting much better and far
better than anything we had preceding
that
so for
you know at least the early part of
application of deep learning and natural
language processing
neural machine translation was the huge
big success story um in the last few
years when we've had um models like gpt2
and gpt3
and other huge neural models like bird
improving
web search you know it's a bit more
complex but this was the first area
where there was a neural network which
was hugely better than what it proceeded
and was actually solving a practical
problem that lots of people in the world
need
and it was stunning
with the speed at which success was
achieved
so
were the first um what i call here
fringe research attempts um to build in
your machine translation system meaning
that um three or four people who were
working on neural network models thought
oh why don't we see if we can use one of
these to translate learn to translate
sentences where they weren't really
people with a background in machine
translation at all but a success was
achieved
so quickly that within two years time
google had switched to using neural
machine translation
for
most languages and by a couple of years
later after that essentially anybody who
does machine translation is now
deploying um live neural machine
translation systems and getting um much
much better results so that was sort of
just an amazing technological transition
that
for the preceding decade the big
statistical machine translation systems
like the previous generation of google
translate had literally been built up by
hundreds of engineers
over years
but a comparatively small group of
deep learning people in a few months
with a small amount of code
and hopefully you'll even get a sense of
this doing assignment 4 we're able to
build
newer machine translation systems that
prove to work much better
does that mean that machine translation
is solved uh no um there are still lots
of different ease which people continue
to work on very actively and you can see
more about it in the sky yet today
article was linked at the bottom but you
know there are lots of problems without
a vocabulary words
they're domain mismatches between the
training and test data so it might be
trained mainly on newswire data but you
want to
translate people's facebook messages
there are still problems with
maintaining context over longer text
we'd like to translate um languages for
which we don't have much data and so
these methods work by far the best when
we have huge amounts of parallel data
even our best
multi-layer lstms aren't that great at
capturing sentence meaning there are
particular problems such as interpreting
what pronouns refer to or in languages
like um chinese or japanese where
there's often no pronoun present but
there is an implied reference to some
person working out how to translate that
for languages the laws have lots of
inflectional forms
of nouns verbs and adjectives these
systems often get them wrong so there's
still tons of stuff to do
so here's just sort of
quick funny examples of the kind of
things that go wrong right so if you've
asked to translate
paper jam
google translate is deciding that this
is a kind of jam just like there's
some raspberry jam
and
strawberry jam and so this becomes a jam
of paper
um
there are problems
of agreement and choice
um so if you have many languages don't
distinguish gender and so the sentences
uh neutral between things are masculine
or feminine so malay or turkish are two
well-known languages of that sort
but what happens when that gets
translated into english by google
translate is that
the
english language model just kicks in and
applies stereotypical biases and so
these gender neutral sentences
get translated into she works as a nurse
he works as a programmer so if you want
to help solve this problem you all of
you can help by using singular they in
all contexts
when you're
putting material online and that could
then change the distribution of what's
generated
but people also
work on modeling improvements to try and
avoid this
here's one more example
that's kind of funny um
people noticed um a couple of years ago
that if you choose one of the rarer
languages
that google will translate um such as
somali
um
that and you just write in some rubbish
like a gay gag um
freakily it would produce out of nowhere
prophetic and biblical texts as the name
of the lord was written in the hebrew
language it was written in the language
of the hebrew nation
which makes no sense at all
we're about to see a bit more about why
this happens um
but but
ah that was sort of a bit worrying um
this as far as i can see this problem is
now fixed in 2021 i couldn't actually
get google translate um to generate
examples like this anymore um
but you know so there's lots of ways to
keep on doing research um
nmt is certainly is you know a flagship
task for nlp and deep learning
and it was a place where many of the
innovations of
deep learning nlp
were pioneered and people continue to
work hard on it people found many many
improvements
um and actually for the last bit of the
class in the minute i'm going to
present one huge improvement which is so
important that it's really come to
dominate the whole of the recent field
of newell
neural networks for nlp and that's the
idea of attention
but before i get on to attention i want
to spend
three minutes on our assignment for
so for assignment four this year um
we've got a new version of the
assignment um which we hope will be
interesting but it's also a real
challenge so for assignment four this
year
we've decided to do cherokee english
machine translation
so cherokee is an endangered native
american language it has about 2 000
fluent speakers
it's an extremely low resource language
so it's just there isn't much
written cherokee data available period
and particularly there's not a lot of
parallel sentences between cherokee and
english
and here's the answer um to the
google's freaky prophetic translations
for languages for which there isn't um
much parallel data available commonly
the biggest place where you can get
parallel data is from bible translations
so you can
have your own personal choice wherever
it is over the map as to
where you stand with respect to religion
but the fact of the matter is if you
work on indigenous languages what you
very um
very quickly find is that a lot of the
work that's done on collecting data on
indigenous languages and a lot of the
material that is available in written
form for many indigenous languages is
bible translations um
yeah okay so this is um what cherokee
looks like
and so
you can see that the writing system has
a mixture of things that look like
english letters and then all sorts of
letters that don't and so here's the
initial
bit of a story long ago was seven boys
who used to spend all their time down by
the townhouse so this is a piece of
parallel data that we can learn from so
um the cherokee writing system has 85
letters and the reason why it has so
many letters is that each of these
letters actually represents a syllable
so many languages of the world
have strict consonant vowel syllable
structure so you have words like rata
per or something like that
or cherokee
right
and another language like that's
hawaiian
and so each of the letters represents a
combination of a consonant and a vowel
and um that's
um the set of those um you then get 17
by five gives you 85 letters
um
yeah so being able to do this assignment
big thanks to um people from university
of north carolina chapel hill um who've
provided the resources um we're using
for this assignment
although you can do quite a lot of
languages on google translate um
cherokee is not a language that google
offers on google translate so we can see
how far um we can get um but we have to
be modest in our expectations because
it's hard to build a very good mt system
with only a fairly limited amount of
data so we'll see how far we can get
there is a flip side which is for you
students doing the
assignment the advantage of having not
too much data is that your models will
train relatively quickly so we'll
actually have less troubles than we did
last year
with people's models taking hours to
train
as the assignment deadline closed in
there's a couple more words about
cherokee so we have some idea what we're
talking about
so the cherokee originally
lived in western north carolina and
tennis eastern tennessee
they then sort of got shunted um
south west from that and then in
particular
for those of you who
went to american high schools and paid
attention you might remember um
discussion of the trail of tears when a
lot of the native americans from the
southeast of the us got forcibly
shoved
a long way further west and so most
cherokee now live in oklahoma though
there's there are some that are in north
carolina
the writing system that i showed on this
previous slide it was invented by a
cherokee
man sequoia that's a
drawing of him there
and that was actually a kind of
incredible thing so um he started off a
literate and
worked out how to
write or
produce a writing system that would be
goodbye good for um cherokee and given
that it has this consummate vowel
structure um he chose a celebrity which
um turned out to be a good choice um so
here's here's a neat historical fact so
in the 1830s and 1840s
um the percentage of cherokee that were
literate
in cherokee written like this was
actually higher than the percentage of
white people in the southeastern united
states at that point in time
okay
before time disappears um
oops time has almost disappeared i'll
just start to say um and then i'll have
to do a bit more of this uh i'll have to
do a bit more of this next time that'll
be okay right so the final idea that's
really important for
sequence to sequence models is the idea
of attention
um and so we had this model
of
doing
sequence to sequence models such as the
neural machine translation
and the problem with this architecture
is that
we have this one hidden state which has
to encode all the information about the
source sentence so it acts as a kind of
an information bottleneck and that's all
the information that the generation is
conditioned on
well
i didn't already mention one idea last
time of how to get more information
where i said look maybe you could kind
of average all of the vectors of the
source to get a sentence representation
but you know that method turns out to be
better for things like sentiment
analysis
and not so good for machine translation
where the order of words is very
important to preserve
so it's it seems like we would do better
if
somehow we could get more information
from the source sentence
while we're generating the translation
and in some sense this just corresponds
to what a human translator does right if
you're a human translator you read the
sentence that you're meant to translate
and you maybe start translating a few
words but then you look back at the
source sentence to see what else was in
it and translate some more words so um
very quickly after the first neural
machine translation systems people came
up with the idea of maybe we could build
a better neural mt model
that did that and that's the idea of a
tension
so the core idea is on each step of the
decoder um we're going to use a direct
link between the encoder and the decoder
that will allow us to focus on
particular
a particular word or words in the source
sequence and use it to help us generate
what words come next
i'll just go through now showing you the
pictures of what attention does and then
at the start of next time we'll go
through the equations in more detail
so we generate we use our encoder just
as before and generate our
representations
feed in our conditioning as before and
say we're starting our translation
but at this point we take this hidden
representation
and say i'm going to use this hidden
representation to look back at the
source to get information directly from
it so what i will do
is i will
compare
the hidden state of the decoder with the
hidden state of the encoder at each
position and generate an attention score
which is a kind of similarity score like
a dot product
and then based on those attention scores
i'm going to calculate a probability
distribution
um as to
by using a softmax as usual to say which
of these encoder states
is most like
my decoder state and so we'll be
training the model here to be saying
well probably you should translate the
first word of the sentence first so
that's where the attention should be
placed
so then based on this attention
distribution which is a probability
distribution coming out of the softmax
we're going to
generate
um a new um attention outport and so
this attention output is going to be an
average of the hidden states of the
encoder model but it's going to be a
weighted average based on our attention
distribution
and so we're then going to take that
attention output combine it with the
hidden state of the decoder rnn
um
and together
the two of them are then going to be
used to predict virus soft max
what word to generate first and we hope
to generate he
and then at that point we sort of chug
along and keep doing these same um kind
of computations at each position
um there's a little side note here that
says um sometimes we take the attention
output from the previous step and also
feed into the decoder along with the
usual decoder input so we're taking this
attention out from actually feeding it
back in
to the
hidden state calculation and that can
sometimes improve performance
and we actually have that trick in the
assignment four system and you can try
it out
okay so we generate along and generate
our whole sentence
in this manner
and that's proven
to be a very effective way of getting
more information from the source
sentence more flexibly to allow us to
generate
a good translation
i'll stop here for now and at the start
of next time i'll finish this off by
going through the actual equations for
how attention works
you